I bought on Twitter I think people on
Twitter as well but you're not on the
gram I'm not first someone named Lorne
Greene I know this is what happened is
so the woman who played my mom on
Gilmore Girls Kelli Bishop who's
incredible who's in the original cast of
A Chorus Line and also dirty dancing and
also dirty dancing and I went to look
her up to find a video of her from a
chorus line and literally when I looked
up I was 72 years old I had been like I
said I had spent so long on the like TV
on the thing like active because I went
through the chorus line and then I was
watching old clips of old other musicals
and it's just not I'm a person who like
opens the refrigerator door and walks
away and forgets like it's just I'm
easily distracted yes yes is the point
and I am worried if I was on Instagram I
would never do anything else you know
what my key is I only use it because I
was against all of it in the beginning
because I was like this is a lot and why
do people care how I like my coffee
right why are there so many food posts
like I don't care you're eating and it's
probably your skin and you're eating
something I want to eat and I can't I
don't so it's just like I just started
doing it just for work I thought it was
it was kind of cool because fans gets it
like I'm a nerd over you so it's kind of
cool because fans get to see stuff or
whatever they get a little insight but I
get it it's a lot all the things is a
lot but it's fun
I I have met some wonderful people who I
admire you know yeah and that's the
connectivity about of all that stuff is
really nice yeah I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this